this is Jocko podcast number 238 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening sir you may
have heard me tell a story in the past
about a training tool that we used for
young seal officers this special
training tool was a stick not to hit him
with but to give them to hold in place
of their weapon in place of their gun if
they couldn't detach from their instinct
to shoot and replace that instinct with
an instinct to lead because the leaders
job is not to engage the enemy the
leaders job is to make tactical
decisions to direct the troops find the
next move that we're gonna take the
leaders job is to actually lead there is
a story another story of an ancient
Chinese military leader who on the eve
of battle was offered a sword from his
subordinate leaders which he did not
accept no I don't want your sword I
don't want that sword because to him
banners banners and drums which is how
you would signal back in the day this is
how you would direct troops during this
time period those were the tools of a
leader for him and he said to them to
command the troops and direct their
blades as the role of a commander to
wield a single sword is not his role
correct
this leader was named Wu Chi he lived
from 440 to 381 BC a philosopher
military philosopher politician and
military leader he led troops in combat
many battles I want to say the number
was like like 60 battles 63 battles or
something like that during the period in
history called the warring States Period
he ended up becoming the prime minister
of the state of Chu and there he was he
led a lot of reforms he was kind of a he
was like a default aggressive leader a
little bit radical he would make things
happen he would fire incompetent leaders
spent bunch of money on the military
tried to build it up he eliminated these
old hereditary privileges that they had
back in the day so you can imagine
that's gonna make some people angry
mm-hmm and he did other things that were
good for the state but or let's just say
against the norm made things happen
on the battlefield and in the
bureaucracy and luckily he wrote down
some of these military philosophies in
something called the Wu Zi W you see I I
couldn't really figure out what that
word meant other than what was it room
like in Chinese the word Wu Zi means
room I know that's not what that we're
talking about here so and I couldn't
find any other information about it so
just called the woozy I'm sure some
people will give us some information
about that but there's a lot of there's
a lot of good information in this book
once again written in
I don't know sometime before 381 BC
which is crazy to think about mm-hmm
that's crazy to think about yeah like a
lot of that time even though if you look
at old pictures like the end of the
old-school black-and-white pictures
you're looking at and it's like dang
that's like you know you understand what
a photograph is it's a capture of real
it's basically capture of light coming
through this thing and a record of it
right then but what it says is this
right here in this little frame right
here this actually happened here this
was a actual point in time right here
there's the person there's the people
whatever and yeah you trip out when you
find out like how long ago that was yeah
it's weird and now thinking that
somebody this guy woochi wrote the woozi
in 381 BC that's crazy the idea of your
very existence was non-existent yeah not
even close to being exist I mean can you
imagine trying to pull the string on
your genealogy you're going to find out
where the ancestors were back then yeah
it's crazy
yeah and compared to who kind of you are
whatever yeah yeah you can go deep a
little rabbit hole let's go deep in the
woozi first section we're jumping right
in the need for strengthening domestic
and external issues and this is sort of
set up like a story which is kind of
weird cuz I don't know if he wrote it
this way or if people captured his words
but it's written not like too much of a
story but it says this woochi dressed in
Confucian attire had an audience of the
Lord when of way to discuss about
military issues this is this is one of
those situations where I was like oh you
know what if this will be good I hadn't
read it no I'd like looked at it there's
there's I think it's the seven ancient
Chinese war texts this is one of them
Sun Tzu is one of them right
I've glanced through this one but I
couldn't remember enough about it to
think oh yeah I gotta do this one here's
the opening so Lord went away said I'm
not interested in military affairs
woochi replied this is like him saying
hey wait a second it might not be a good
call my brother he says from the visible
facts I can deduce the hidden from the
past I can discern the future
how can your lordship say this topic
does not accord with your thoughts he's
coming off the top roads rope in the
Overland this is in the opening from the
visible facts I can deduce the hidden
from the past I can discern the future
how can you not want to know what I'm
what I've got interestingly you know a
shell on front sometimes will get a
client as well you know you're talking a
lot about a military stuff this is what
I'm gonna tell him from now on
I'm gonna say wait a second from visible
facts I can deduce the hit so then he
continues but this is some of these
lines are routinely so then he says this
throughout the four seasons you have
gathered the skins of wild animals
covered them with with lacquer painted
them with colors and embellished them
with glistening images of rhinoceroses
and elephants wearing them and so he's
talking about making these garments
these really fancy garments mm-hmm and
then he says this wearing them in winter
does not keep one warm wearing them in
summer does not make one cool so you've
done all this you make all these fancy
things they have no real purpose and
he's kind of setting this up to say
moreover the Lord has ordered the making
of 24 feet and 12 feet long Hal Birds
which is like up you ever seen those
Spears that have instead of having up
just a point they have like an axe
looking thing on it oh yeah so that's
what that is so he's made he's he's
ordered to make 24-foot ones and 12-foot
once and had leathers to cover the
chariots these chariots are not granted
at all these chariots are not mobile
enough for hunting meaning they're not
beautiful so they're not made for shell
they're not mobile enough for hunting so
they're they're made for one thing he
says I have no idea what you have what
you should have for them if they are to
be used for war but your Lord does not
seek capable people who are adept in
using them such a situation is similar
to a nesting hen fighting against a fox
or a bitch
fighting a tiger yeah this guy's built
up some cool-looking things what do you
got he's a paper tiger right I've got
nobody that knows how to operate these
things although they have great fighting
spirit they will still die in the past
the lord of chiang saen clan focused on
improving the culture and domestic
issues but neglected military affairs
thereby leading to the extinction of the
state the lord of yoo-hoo clan was
belligerent
thus he focused on military affairs and
neglected domestic affairs he too led
the state to extinction so he gives two
examples one guy focused on domestic and
didn't care about the military they fell
apart one was just belligerent and
making war all the time but not taking
care of the domestic that fell apart the
enlightened ruler would have used such
examples to remind him that he should
tend to both domestic affairs and
military affairs together when the enemy
comes and you do not fight them such
does not count as righteousness when the
enemy comes and you do not fight them
such does not count as righteousness so
enemies coming at you you gotta fight
him when you all this is a good one when
you only start grieving the death of
your soldiers after they have died such
does not count as benevolence man you
got to take care of your soldiers before
they die hmm and then it says thereupon
Lord when personally laid a mat for Wu
Chi and his wife and presented
with the goblet of wine the Lord later
invited Wu Chi to the ancestral temple
and appointed him as a
commander-in-chief for the defense of
the western rivers you know he's a guy
this guy's got some he got some goods
puts him in charge
from then on whoo cheers oh I was wrong
he knocked out a couple more winning 64
of them decisively the other battles
resulted in draw he expanded ways
territory in all directions
broadening ways border by a thousand by
a thousand Lee which is about a third of
a mile all of these were wood cheese
accomplishments so isn't it cool that
he's just got a record like an MMA
fighter he's like yeah hey 76 bottles
64 64 wins and whatever the number is
draws
that's his record this dude's got a a
combat battle record it's freakin legit
all right now it goes into unity and the
people's support so that's the opener
and and this thing is pretty
straightforward pretty straightforward
it jumps goes through pretty succinct
sections this part's called a unity and
people support Wu Chi said in antiquity
the ruler who planned to run his state
well would teach the enlight teach and
enlighten the people be close to the
people and understand their sufferings
do I not talk about this all the time
like you gotta understand where your
people are coming from you know you've
got to understand their perspective and
you know I use that I don't know if I do
you think it's it's okay or do you think
that I have some kind of a subliminal
problem with the word empathy I don't
know I I guess maybe I did because I
always say you got to understand other
people's perspective mm-hmm that whole
word can be replaced with just that
whole sentence can be just be saved
empathy yeah that's
yeah I know I know so I guess I have
some sort of a natural prejudice against
that word yeah you know maybe it's
something where in my mind it sounds a
little too soft too soft we're not doing
it
yeah like the word like the word moist I
don't know why but that I don't like
that word yeah even when you know some
words I don't like it when I say it but
other people can say it really okay that
makes sense I don't care but moist is
one that anyone says one way it sounds
or just the thoughts it gives you but
all of the the whole deal when someone
else says it like Oh even like you know
I you know I step here in the ground and
it was moist I'm like bro don't say
something else man's a damp I don't know
actually damp damp sounds drier than
moist yeah right yeah you see it was
kind of wet or I don't know man just
don't say I'm saying yeah and I'll
refrain from seeing it too it's kind of
that feeling yeah so that's what we're
dealing with you yes what he's talking
about is empathy what I say is
perspective but we're all saying the
same thing you got to understand your
people there are four disc harmonies the
ruler should take note of if there is
disharmony in the state you cannot start
a military campaign if there is
disharmony disharmony within the army
they cannot be allowed to battle if
there is disharmony within the formation
they cannot be used to lead an attack if
there is a lack of cohesion during the
conduct of battle you cannot score a
victory what does that mean you got to
be unified as a group for this reason
the eminent ruler before he employs his
people he would unite them first before
achieving great matters together the
ruler this is why when you're in a team
and you're doing anything that is
pulling the team apart you're not doing
a good job as a leader hmm the ruler
will not dare rely solely on his own
plans but will announce formally at the
at the ancestral temple I have when I
was reading this I was like oh this is
gonna be decentralized commander but is
not really you actually have to announce
it at your ancestral temple and then and
then sort of
get the divine sort of approval from the
heavens that's what it's talking about
which is still cool like I'm not down
with that but I was hoping you'd be a
little bit more focused on decentralized
command than the higher power but then
he says people will then know that the
ruler value their lives will be sorrowed
by their deaths and willing to share
weal and woe with them new word w/e al
Weill and what it means is well just
take the th off yeah use it a couple
times you but it's a great expression
yeah you got a little alliteration Ham
willing to share weal and woe so good or
bad yeah thick doesn't help where there
you go
Whelan well I got I think weal and woe
might be better yeah officers will then
consider death while advancing is
glorious and life gained through a
treating is disgraceful so all these
things what does it mean you got to
build a tight team you got to have good
relationships up and down the chain of
command you kind of suffer with your
troops you've got to reward them when
there's rewards to be given oh good
stuff that's it that's on unity and
people support next section for virtues
of a ruler Wu Chi said the way is
actually knowing is actually how things
should be done it means it is the means
by which one can turn back to foundation
and return to beginning righteousness is
ethical behavior it is the means by
which to achieve great accomplishments
strategizing is the means by which to
harm distant keep harm distant and gain
benefits so you strategize so you keep
harm distant and you gain benefits
principles are which to preserve duty
and keep achievements if one's behavior
does not accord with the way and
righteousness but dwells in Magnifico
mad
emphasis and enjoys power disaster will
inevitably befall him you got to keep
that ego in check if you dwell in
magnificence and you enjoy power
you got this Astor coming your way thus
the white ruler will run the state
according to the way manage the state
with righteousness orders that order the
people with propriety and rule the
people with benevolence cultivating
these four virtues and the state will
flourish neglecting them would lead to
decline well take care of your people
and your people will take care of you I
wrote that in leadership strategy and
tactics that's the expression in the
seal themes was take care of your gear
and your gear will take care of you it
doesn't seem like a huge leap to say
take care of your people and your people
will take care of you but man that's a
good thing to remember and that's what
my boy
woochi is saying right here take care of
your people and your people are going to
take care of you righteousness and doing
the right thing is another thing I said
do the right things for the right
reasons
death that's righteousness next section
running the state and victory
woochi said in general to govern the
state and the army you must instruct
them with propriety motivate them with
righteousness and instill a sense of
shame in them when men have a sense of
shame
one can to a large degree wage a war or
to a lesser degree preserve the state
what does that mean it means it reminds
me of World War one in England have you
ever heard of what we talked around this
podcast they used to give the white
flour til if you were a military aged
male and you weren't in uniform meaning
you weren't serving and everyone else
was going overseas and fighting they
would give you all white flour like a
real way like a real white flour and it
was shame
yeah it was shame and you know that
that's one of the things that just drove
those men to go and fight in that awful
war yeah you know everyone is dying
everyone is being wounded everyone is
being killed it's a total nightmare you
know what was worse than that my flower
shame yeah and that's what he's saying
Scarlet Letter yeah old-school yeah hey
yeah thus it is said that for all strong
states those that garner five victories
will meet with disaster so if you win
five times you're gonna meet with
disaster four victories you're gonna
decline three victories you're gonna
achieve hegemony which means you're like
kind of in control those with two
victories can claim to be kings and
those with only one victory will become
Emperor's for this reason those who have
conquered through numerous victories are
rare while those that perished because
of it are many this reminds me of the
disease of victory it's like the more
you win the better chance you can have a
following next reasons for war and it's
counter strategies Wu Chi said there are
five reasons why wars are started and
they are to contend for fame to contend
for benefits and advantages to seek
revenge internal strife and famine the
names of wars raised based on these
reasons are righteous bully anger
plundering contrary the righteous army
is raised to save people from chaos
relying on strength or power to bully
people such as a bully army mobilizing
an army out of anger is an anger army an
army raised to greedily seek profit
without consideration for moral and
ethics is called a plundering army while
the country is in turmoil and the people
are exhausted embarking on military
campaigns and mobilizing masses is
termed contrary interesting viewpoints a
bully army next section managing troops
selecting talents strengthening
now we go to a little Q&A from the Lord
whoo Lord Wu said I would like to hear
your thoughts on managing troops
selecting talents and strengthening
nation Wu Chi said from antiquity
enlightened rulers always make every
effort to maintain propriety between
themselves and their ministers manifest
the distinction of rank allow the allow
the officials and people to settle into
their respective positions that accord
with their customs select and recruit
talents in order to prepare for the
unexpected pretty straightforward he
says the ruler of a strong state must
evaluate his people first and then he
breaks this down a little bit those who
have courage and strength should be
assembled into a unit those who take
pleasure in advancing into battle and
exerting their strength so as to
manifest their loyalty and courage
should be assembled into another unit
those who are nimble and fleet should be
assembled into another unit officials
who have lost their position and are
eager to make amends should be assembled
into a unit those who have lost in war
and want to eradicate their disgrace
should be assembled into a unit these
five will serve to be the elite troops
with 3,000 of such men one can break any
encirclement or break into any city
those are kind of some cool people to
think about right yeah you know we got
the people that just love to fight we've
got people that want to prove their
loyalty got people that are quick we got
people that have lost their position you
know look I think those are the people
you got to watch out for yeah right yeah
I guess I mean on the surface anyway it
seems like you'd have to watch out for
some sort of infighting scenario maybe
in some of those but otherwise it's like
yeah you send out your little Ely
what he saw specialized forces you know
these guys they like to do this so
listen them in under these circumstances
you know it's interesting it's like
weapons like tools you know you know
what it's interesting to think about
from like Oh what you should actually do
is understand human nature and know what
you're dealing with right like you've
got somebody that gets defeated somebody
that you know loses a client
how do they react to it they might be
ready to go boss
put me in coach yeah right you might
have somebody that gets defeated and
gets broken down yeah Gunja gotta pay
attention to that stuff next section
strengthen offense and defense Lord woo
further inquiry I would like to hear
your views on making battle formations
stable defense impregnable and victory
in battle certain that's kind of a
massive question how do you make my
defense impregnable and victory in
battles certain what's would she say to
that he replied
Bucci replied what I am saying is not
only for hearing carrying them out would
allow you to see immediate effect so
he's saying if you did what I said you
could put those men together you're
gonna get immediate effect he's actually
stepping up he's like oh that's your
question if you have worthy men hold
high positions and relatively less
worthy men occupy low position than your
battle formations are stable if people
settle down into the respective
positions respect their local
authorities than defense is solid when
the people support the policies of their
government and not concerned about those
of other states than in battle you will
already be victorious this is a very
interesting concept that picture you
have a team this is this this would
happen the SEAL Teams sometimes they put
together these I kind of super platoons
where they would take a bunch of really
good guys and put them in there and all
of a sudden what you have is a bunch of
alphas in the same platoon and do you
think that works out well what's your
guess
well well the fact that you brought it
up because I think no but why because
everyone has a rhyme in the simple
answer is like everyone's trying to be
the Alpha right kind of thing but yeah
it's like in a team like just like all
those guys right there's like different
types of guys for different jobs and a
team there's different jobs typically so
it's interesting that he would say what
he's saying is you know you put your
alphas in there you put an alpha in
there and then you put some betas in
there and then everyone kind of goes
into their natural position is gonna be
the most positive thing now here's what
I'll tell you in life you're not always
going to be put in that situation and
you might be the Alpha mmm
and you get put in with another alpha so
now what are you gonna do if you're
smart what you'll do is subordinate your
ego support that other person or you
know maybe you're just enough maybe they
do that but what you don't want to do is
fight with that person you're ruining
the team yeah there's a these things
called logical fallacies it's like a
bunch of them or whatever and that's one
of them and they're there's actually two
of them that are kind of one is one and
then the other is this like flipped
around and it's it's essentially that
where it's like individuals like if an
individual is a level five and you get
you put three of them in there that
makes it a level 15 it's not the case
it's logically it seems the case but
it's like a fallacy for that reason yeah
and then the inverse is right to where
it's like if you have a team worth
fifteen if you just break them up you
got three fives rolling around
performing at five that's not true
either because they can function better
together for that exact same reason but
it's like the inverse fallacy yeah I
never get what it's called you can have
a leadership team that just completely
complements each other and they can be
unstoppable then you pull one person out
or you pull two people out of that team
they fall apart yeah yeah or at the very
least level down you know yeah so yeah I
mean it makes sense when you think about
it but there's so many it's weird I was
like reading all these files house like
can us true that's a whole thing and
it's because you automatically think
these things you know this has a bunch
of them but yeah that makes sense
importance of seeking talent there once
was there was once when Lord woo was
planning state affairs
none of his ministers could be equal to
him after dismissing the court he wore a
happy and satisfied look so he there he
is he's running the show he's like and
I'm smarter than everybody this is
awesome
woochi saw that and said there was once
Lord Shang of Chu was planning state
affairs with his ministers he discovered
that none of his ministers could equal
his intelligence after he had dismissed
the court he looked very troubled
official Shen asked him why does your
lordship war such troubled countenance
you know that why do you look so bummed
out and he said I am NOT talented
yet none of my ministers are equal to me
our state is in deep trouble and then
when when heap when Wu Chi tells the
story the guy he's talking to gets
embarrassed because what does that
statement say that statement says
surround your people with bet Pete
surround yourself with people that are
better than you smarter than you that's
what that says if you're smarter than if
you're the smartest person in the room
you're on a losing team
you should feel horrible national next
section National alertness Lord Wu
addressed Wu tree at present kin coerces
us on the West Chu encircles us in the
South shall collides with me in the
north and kee encroaches us from the
East Yan cuts off our rear and Han
occupies the front these six states
around us and we have to defend against
them our situation is precarious and it
worries me what can be done about this
Wu Chi said in general being alert of
danger is true measure of good
governance ensuring security of the
state as you have now recognized the
importance of being cautious disaster
can be kept away so the guys surround
and he's like what can I do pay
attention to it nothing too miraculous
there next next section providing
opportunity for talent within the army
there will be soldiers whose courage is
that of a tiger has strengths that he
can lift tripods easily and has the
fleetness of a barbarian horse I tried
to figure out there's some rude word to
tripods it's like a stool a three-legged
desk I couldn't find that there was some
ancient thing that was really heavy so
we're just going with that we have to
use our imaginations on that one to
seize enemy's flag or kill enemies
generals you need such men you should
select them and put them into one unit
honor them and favor them this is
because in their hands holds the fate of
the whole army those who are experts in
weapons strong and quick and capable and
motivated to kill enemies they should be
given rank and prominence we should also
treat the family well encourage them
with the rewards and warn them with
punishment
this is because such people can solidly
hold their position for a long time and
exterminate enemies if the ruler can
discern and evaluate men described you
can attack double force your strength
Lord Liu exclaimed great people you know
you can ask that question a lot you know
what do you do when you get the high
performers on a team right do you focus
on them and clearly the answer here is
yes and that's usually the answer that I
give as well you do have to keep a bench
right you have to have some other people
and you have to continue to work to get
your bench to become high performers so
you don't ignore the bench when you get
the opportunity to give them some
playing time get them some playing time
hmm but definitely focus on those ones
that are definitely gonna get up there
and make things happen
enemies you can attack next section Wu
Chi said in general when evaluating the
enemy there are eight conditions under
which one engages battle without doing
an assessment you have to think about
these these are no-brainers these are go
criteria in violent wins and extreme
close they arise early and are on the
march while barely awake and breaking
ice to cross streams these guys are cold
they're miserable and they're tired you
can just attack them next one in the
burning heat of summer they arise late
and press forward with haste through
hunger and thirst concentrating on
reaching far-off objectives you see them
attack them the Army has been out in the
field for an extended period their food
supplies are exhausted the people are
resentful and angry numerous bail for
poor tents arises with the officers
unable to squash them you see them
attack them the army's resources have
been already been exhausted firewood and
hair scarce weather frequently cloudy
and rainy and if they even wanted to
plunder for supplies there's nowhere to
do it cleared hot attack them
the troops that are mobilized are not
large the terrain and water not
advantageous the men and horses are sick
and worn out with no assistance from
Rollins attack them the road is far off
in the Sun is setting the officers and
men have labored long and are fearful
they are tired and have not eaten now if
you just cast aside their armor attack
them
the generals are weak the official
irresponsible the officers and troops
are not solid the whole army is
frequently in fear and the troops lack
assistance attack of their formations
are not yet formed their encampment not
yet finished or they are passing through
dangerous territory only half their
troops are out of it in these eight
conditions you can attack without any
doubts enemies you cannot attack other
end of the spectrum there are six
circumstances without performing too
much assessment you should avoid
conflict the land is broad and vast the
people are wealthy and numerous avoid
conflict the government loves the people
the ruler the rulers goodness extends
and flows to all isn't that an
interesting one when you have a ruler
that takes care of his people don't even
attack them hmm think about that think
about that as a leader how you treat
your team we need to treat your team
well when you take care of your team the
enemy shouldn't even attack you because
they know what's gonna happen yeah well
not to interrupt that what so this
you're reading from a paper right now
where did you get that like it obviously
it's a book I got it from the depths of
the internet what is it like a PDF
situation you know you know I don't I
see I a lot of times in my life when I'm
browsing the Internet yeah when I find a
good document I just download that
document or I copy-paste it and I put it
into this file which is called books and
PDFs so in this thing books and PDFs
sometimes I'll I'll go oh yeah see
something to remind me of it or I'll
think of it and I'll just go and and go
in there and that's worse oh I forget
where this actually came from because it
was just in my personal file that says
books and PDFs which is filled with
ancient military documents and have
field manuals and that's so that's where
it came from so yeah I'm sure you could
go google it and you can find it on the
internet somewhere yeah number three
rewards and Punishment system is fair
and transparent and is implemented in a
timely fashion
you shouldn't even attack somebody that
treats their people fairly and
transparently think about that number
four people are rewarded according to
their accomplishment and the talented
are unable are employed I've got a
talented team we're not going to employ
forces are massive and well-equipped I
think that is pretty self-evident they
have assistants of all their neighbors
than the support of a powerful state ok
cool
so those those were maybe both those
sections a little obvious hmm well which
makes you wonder why you have to say it
and I know the answer to the question
that I just asked the reason that you
have to say it is cuz people still don't
even execute on things that seem really
obvious like hey where the forces are
massive and well equipped we we should
not attack them but go look at history
as obvious as it is people do it all
time yeah yeah one of those things where
it's like ok these are you gonna work
hard or are you gonna work smart ideally
both I get it but you know when people
are faced you know in in the mix and
it's like work hard work smart it's kind
of like ok not a lot of people say I
mean I don't wanna say not a lot but I'm
just saying there are people let's say
on a normal level quantity wise who are
gonna be like hey hard all day mm-hm and
turn their back on the smart part you
know I guess it seems understandable
yeah if you know I mean detached it's
kind of like sure I'm gonna play this
the smartest I possibly can I have force
for sure but i'ma play this the smartest
given how much force I have big small
whatever
yeah the follow that makes sense but I
guess it's maybe not the most obvious
here's the deal
it's so obvious from the outside right
it's watching a movie it's watching a
lame horror movie where you're watching
the girl you know with hear a noise
downstairs in the basement everybody
knows she goes down there barefoot like
super obvious yeah but happens all the
time not just in movies people do dumb
stuff yeah a lot people do dumb stuff a
lot check if in general if you are no
match for the enemy in these areas
without a doubt avoid them this is what
I meant by see possibility and advance
knowing difficulty and withdraw so if
you see possibility advance if you see
difficulty withdraw pretty
straightforward next section detecting
the enemy's situation Lord woo acquired
from the external appearance I would
love to be able to know their internal
situations from their advance I would
know their objective from these I am
able to predict victory or defeat what
is your opinion of this woochi replied
if the enemy approaches in large numbers
but in disarray their flags and
formations are a mess and the troops
frequently look about but using by using
1/10 of their strength we can invariably
cause them to be helpless so if they're
just looking ragtag no factor if
reinforcements if reinforcements has not
arrived there is disunity within the
troops preparations for defense has not
been completed orders and rules have not
been announced the morale of the army is
shaken they cannot advance or retreat
you can defeat the enemy with half of
its strength and never lose it all
what's interesting about this perception
is when my first deployment to Iraq we
were running around and thin-skinned
Humvees meaning there was no armor it
was just super sketch and one of the
things we did we would actually briefed
that everyone was responsible for
scanning targets look
and making our convoy look like a convoy
that you don't want to you don't want to
upset so we called it the porcupine of
death because we had we had guys in the
back of our Humvees we had these we had
articulating weapons so we had weapons
mounted crew-served weapons mounted on
articulating arms you've got one of
those on each side you probably had
another couple machine gunners in the
back anyways they've got their weapons
pointed out you've got everyone has got
a weapon pointed out of that vehicle
you've also got the turret gunner except
for the driver the drivers the only one
that's not pointing a weapon so those
were some if you were looking at that
and you see five Humvees and you see I
don't know there's six guns on each
Humvee and some of them are you know
heavy caliber weapons belt-fed machine
guns as I'm thinking about it even right
now I'm thinking if I was an insurgent I
would probably wait till the next convoy
where it's all buttoned up that you know
people are sitting inside there looking
straight ahead we've turned to their
seats on the Humvees because we did have
doors we turned the seats to face
outwards for two reasons one so that we
could see and have a better angle to
shoot but also because our chest plates
of our body armor would be then facing
the enemy as opposed to sitting where
they can shoot you in the side but just
just imagine you know so we would ride
like are facing sideways yeah and our
feet are are out of the vehicle and
we're just scanning for targets and so
when you see these of these you think
you know what yeah it's not mess with
these guys gun barrels pointing at you
no matter where yeah no matter where you
are we call that that was our posture
yeah and we wanted to have an aggressive
posture and we most certainly did we
also you know and those were the were
the Mad Max days so we welded these big
crazy
you know bumpers on them and we'd put
tires on the front so we just get
aggressive
mmm get aggressive while driving
and my point is we didn't we got
ambushed a few times but when you
consider the amount of time we were on
the road I think there was probably
quite a few insurgents or enemy that
decided maybe they'd wait till the next
convoy Nextup weaknesses you can attack
are there circumstances where the enemy
can invariably be attacked Lord Wuan
quired whoo whoo cheering employing the
army you must ascertain the enemy's
strengths and weaknesses if you spot an
opportunity to attack attack his
weaknesses below are the situations you
can attack an enemy when the enemy has
just arrived from afar and their battle
formations are not yet properly formed
and deployed again this is get running
through a list of things that seem
really kind of obvious if they have just
eaten and not less yet establish their
encampment they can be attacked if they
are on the move and the troops formation
is disarray they can be attacked if they
have labored hard they can be attacked
if they not seized advantages of the
terrain they can be attacked when they
have not seized any critical the
critical timing they can be attacked
when their flags and banners move about
chaotically they can be attacked when
they have traversed a great distance
their supplies and reinforcements just
arrived and the whole troops have not
rested they can be attacked it goes on
when River when crossing the river and
only half of them across they can be
attacked on treacherous terrain on
narrow roads they can be attacked when
formations trains frequently changed
frequently they can be attacked when a
general is separated from his soldiers
they can be attacked when they are
afraid they can be attacked in general
in such circumstances
select crack troops and make a swift
attack on them divide remaining troops
and continue the assault repeatedly
factors in using troops Lord Wu asked in
using troops what is primary Wu Chi
replied first you need to be clear about
the four principles of lightness the two
principles of heaviness and the one
principle on integrity Lord Liu asked
what are they Wu Chi said these are kind
of cool the four principles of lightness
means the terrain that the horses the
terrain feels that the horses are light
the horses will feel that the chariot is
light the chariots will feel that the
soldiers on it are light and the
soldiers feel that the burden of war is
light and he breaks it down a little bit
more the terrain feels that the horses
means that one should choose a suitable
terrain that would not hamper the
movement of the horses thus the terrain
would feel that the horses are light if
the horses are properly fed they will be
strong and thus when they are pulling
chariots they would feel that the
chariots are light if the axles of the
chariots are well-oiled and sturdy and
properly maintained they can move
soldiers easily thus the chariots will
feel that the soldiers are light if the
soldiers have sharp weapons and their
armor are sturdy they will feel
confident about winning thus the burden
of war will be light first so there's
the four lights for the courageous that
advance they should be rewarded heavily
for those that retreat they should be
punished heavily so there's the two
heavies there four lights two heavies
and the last one is integrity there are
two principles these are the two
principles of heaviness as for integrity
it refers to the integrity of rewards
and Punishment system if the ruler is to
take note and implement these principles
the troops can achieve victory it all
kind of starts with picking good terrain
man it was a that so much focus if
you're if you're in combat arms so much
focus should be on understanding terrain
and then as you map that into the
civilian sector and jobs and and
businesses you need to understand what
the terrain is the that what's the
market like what where are people
located where your competitors what is
their encampment like you can translate
this stuff and you can utilize to read
that's the thing terrain on the
battlefield is is the best weapon right
it's like positioning in jiu-jitsu that
when you get the right terrain it's like
you have a good position in jiu-jitsu
mmm when you get good terrain in
business you have that kind of massive
advantage gaining control of the army
Lord we ask what measures will ensure
the soldiers will be victorious this
guy's asking these questions this is
kind of like those questions that are
hey how do you how do you pass the how
do you pass the dog right how do you get
around the legs you know but Wu Chi has
an answer because we choose not playing
control is for most Lord Wu asked again
is it not a matter of numbers Wu Chi
says if the laws and orders are not
clear rewards and punishments not met
meted out when the sounding of the gongs
will not cause him to halt or the
beating of the drums will not make them
advance even if you have a million men
what use are they control is achieved by
training and management at any time
discipline is strict and during war they
move and attack with all their advance
and withdraw stride is measured the left
and right look out for each other even
if we cover move even if broken off from
the main order they preserve their
formations decentralized command if they
scatter
they will reform lines the whole army is
very United and share weal and woe
together when they are employed they do
not feel tired
no matter where you dispatch them no one
can withstand them such armies are
called the father-and-son army doesn't
go any more detail about the
father-and-son army but that whole thing
you know decentralized command
discipline when they are employed they
do not feel tired think about that right
think about that think about that Union
your personal life like you can be tired
it going into a workout and I mean
mentally tired man I'm tired I want to
go to sleep when you start working out
and you're actively engaged you're not
tired anymore mm-hmm I never feel tired
when I'm actually doing something you
know seriously that's crazy right yes it
is crazy I mean I have to stop doing
something and then I can get tired takes
about 40 minutes yeah actually that
makes sense but it does depend on what
kind of tired you're talking about so
you know how there's like the three
tires I don't know about the three tires
nothing I know that one is obviously
physically tired so when you're working
out and you're doing your third set of
burpees as fast as you can yeah you
that's a different kind of time yeah
yeah so you can of this one is that one
is that type one tired that's type two
and three tired yes oh and keep in mind
I said the three tires like it's this
known thing the the type 3 the 3 types
of tired is the three types of tired
that I recognize in myself ok so the
ancient principles of echo charlie well
sleepy tired sleepy times I which is
that the doctrinal name for it the
sleepy time yes ok so far yes uh that's
the one you're talking about where
you're a little sleepy tired but you're
not the other two tick kinds of tired
you can just warm up a little bit get
the blood flowing
you know maybe boost some adrenaline in
some capacity and you're you're rolling
you're good to go
you stop you're gonna go back to sleep
you're tired a little bitter then
there's like then there's lung is tired
meaning like my muscles are working but
I'm breathing so hard that I like relief
is like you just need you need really
from that so you gotta rest whatever
long we be tired lungs tired and then we
have muscular killer tired like straight
up muscles can't be this bar anymore
yeah so in jujitsu like all of those
kind of come into play where a sleepy
tired yeah so you can be sleepy tired
before you get on the mass but once you
start rolling it goes away that's how
you recover from sleepy tired in
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu sleepy tired comes
before the role you same thing so now in
jiu-jitsu you can have a guy a real fast
pace guy and you'll be lungs tired like
you'll be like discussion but muscular
you can still push him but you're just
breathing so hard and he gets you in
some kind of claustrophobic situation
you're in big trouble depends on who you
are of course but if your muscular
fatigue tired you're not like breathing
hard you know like I mean that I guess
typically happens if you're like really
not in shape and you go like a few
rounds you know or if he or if you just
been rolling all day well did well
actually where I get muscular tired is
like you you either are giving or
receiving a singular move for an
extended period of time
ie you get my arm and I'm defending for
four and a half minutes yeah muscular
time yeah you can't yeah and you'll be
muscular tired too by the way yeah right
happens to both of us yeah well you know
you know obviously depend on how good a
shape certain muscles or muscle groups
whatever and it can apply the individual
muscles or parts to your body or your
whole body like you ever felt like but
my body is all getting up is like it's
like your whole body is muscular tired
but you're not breathing hard or nothing
you're just like oh I'm dead you know
kind of thing it's like you know if you
roll for like a long time that tends to
happen in my experience anyway yeah but
yeah that's three times three types of
tired ancient echo Charles doctrine you
fully sleepy tired that's my favorite
one about sleepy tired because you know
that's the same word right well you know
what the Eskimos have what where they
always say yes compose have a hundred
words for snow or something like that
well the Hawaiians have two words for
water so it's like okay what two words
well actually there might be more but
there's water like on a river in this
there's the ocean water because they're
like different things you know in their
mind even though they're made of the
same liquid whatever h2o I guess
sometimes the salt in one of a but no
you see how they can be different from a
certain approach you see them saying do
they know the two Hawaiian words for
water
yeah vine Kai which one's wet
why is river water or like lakes or you
know like what what with you we're gonna
ask for a drink of water what would
y'all see I don't know that's that's
another one that could be a whole
different thing my chest back with our
people yeah
figure out what the deal is there oh
yeah and that's why like there's a lot
of like towns and even names or whatever
they'll have Chi in them or vibe of
spelled WWE so Chi ka is the ocean water
that's they're referring to the ocean
waters the people named Kai - exactly
right hi something you know or it could
be part of it you know like you can you
can have names like you know I know or
you know Kyle on here this and that and
Kalani roughly translates to beautiful
ocean
Lani is like beautiful or you know
loving or something you know it's
there's a bunch of translations for sure
we're not putting you on the spot yeah
I'm Dean deep in my head you know Hawaii
Hawaii on it right now
but nevertheless yes Kai you if you say
ma Kai that's like a let's like a
position / location but I means towards
the ocean yeah and say mauka that means
towards the mountain the mountainside
yeah mountainside exactly but anyway yes
three words for tired and two words for
water in Hawaiian and you know cool here
you go alright we're gonna go with that
I like it next one notes on marching
armies Wu Chi said in general the way to
command a marching army is not to contra
intervene not to contravene the proper
timing advancement and stopping not miss
the appropriate times for eating and
drinking and not completely exhausted
strength of men and horses these three
are the means by which troops can
undertake the orders from their
superiors when the orders of the
superiors are followed control is
achieved if advancing and resting are
not a proper timing the drinking and
eating are not timely when the horses
are tired didn't men are weary and not
allowed to relax an encampment then they
will be unable to carry out the
commander's order if they're unable to
carry out the order they're gonna be
defeated up Dave Burke got asked good
deal yes
asked a question today on EF online and
and this one this one guy named Evan was
asking you know hey my team right now
needs to get after it big-time
mm-hmm and we can't take a break but
people are burned out and if we don't
keep going right now we're not gonna
make it and Dave Burke good deal dude
yeah he he said well do you really you
know what I mean like really and then
and he said even the guy said you know
it's like a marathon you know we're in a
marathon and we you know if we stop we
won't finish mm-hmm and Dave's works
like actually you can be in a marathon
and you can stop and you can still
finish actually right if you take a
break and then what did he say max Q oh
yeah so there's three modes of speed in
a jet fighter the max Q is working as
fast as we possibly can max R is hey our
range is we're gonna go as far as we can
mmm we're trying to you're going as fast
you can you might not be able to go as
far as you're burning more fuel and then
the last one was max II which was I
think it's max efficiency meaning we're
just gonna stay flying as long as we can
gotcha yeah and so he said you gotta
know when to push and then you gotta
back off then you push for a second then
you back off and Dave was saying almost
never well he would he said all the time
they would be constantly going between
Max Q max at our Maxie and just going
back and forth between these things real
quick one more time max Q yeah is how
far can we how far and then oh sorry max
Q's is faster we can possibly go and
then know if the Navarro's max yeah is
max Q max arc is now it says yep and
then the last one was max II so R is as
far as you can go straight up whatever
speed we're just trying to get they're
trying to we're trying to get as far as
we can
yeah and then Maxie is like basic
as far as fast no max II is staying in
the air like we want to be able to stay
in the air because there's an optimum
time where we might be going slower but
we're saving a lot of fuel okay yeah and
if we went faster we could go further
but not as long we just want to stay in
the air okay I understand yeah okay that
make sense it's kind of like jujitsu
right yeah it's yeah I mean your body of
similar energy systems yeah what is it
anaerobic anaerobic aerobic and
anaerobic yeah
anaerobic lactic acid and will be
aerobic yeah three systems yeah and
they're a blend it's not like yeah you
know they blend into each other kind of
things so it's not like oh you know next
one decisiveness
woochi said in general I'm gonna change
my voice yeah we gotta go a little heavy
on this one in general on the
battlefield soon to become a land of
corpses if the soldiers are committed to
fighting to death they will live whereas
if they seek to stay alive they will die
gotta be aggressive hmm if you're scared
of dying your chances of dying increase
a general a good general act as if they
are on a sinking boat or trapped in a
burning building there is not enough
time for the Wat two for the wise to
make plans or the courageous to get
angry only thought that one can have is
to fight thus it is said that the
greatest harm can befall an army is the
result of hesitation while the disasters
that befall the whole army is a result
of too much doubts leading to slowness
what did Patton say a good plan executed
now is better than an imperfect plan
executed in two weeks those are good
ones education and training of armies
woochi said in war
constantly perished from their
inabilities and are defeated by
unfamiliar thus when deploying troops
training should be given the priority
one man who has been trained in warfare
can instruct ten men ten men can train a
hundred men Andhra Bank can train a
thousand men a thousand men can train
ten thousand men ten thousand men can
train a whole army use the advantage of
being near to counter enemy that comes
from afar use the advantage being
well-rested to counter an enemy that's
been laboured use the advantage of being
satiated encounter the enemy that is
hungry having them from deploying in
circular formations and change to square
ones have them sit then get up and move
and hold have them Holt move left to
right right to left he's talking about
how to train these people how have them
divided and combine unite them and
disperse them when all these changes are
familiar provide them with weapons all
these mentioned are great I used to do
this with I did is all that I would take
my seal platoon take take myself task
you know go out on the beach we wouldn't
even have we're just be wearing PT
shorts and pairs whatever
sneakers and get in our patrol formation
and then go contact front contact right
contact left center peel peel right
peel left and call these random calls
and people just have to figure it out
and you start going eight you come with
me here's a new call and people start
taking ownership and people start making
things happen you start to see
initiative and you start to see
decentralized command and by the time
you we would get to let's say land
warfare and we'd thrown all this chaos
at all these guys and they got used to
making things happen
it just seemed easy yeah do you know
what seemed like we were cheating yeah
do you run into like in the beginning of
say that kind of exercise whatever like
kind of a chaotic kind of scenario for
sure and then what you just sort of what
give them guidelines or work through it
like but you coach him up like after
little I might but work through it yeah
cuz as you work through it you're
getting better and we've now we would
have a debrief you know maybe go okay
eight or ten little mini maneuvers and
this is you know the classic one is you
you call your first call and everyone
knows what to do and then the
you let that start to get executed then
Rises getting executed you call
different calls oh yeah then as that
one's getting so now you got confusion
times it one then you call a different
thing you get confusion times two now
we're all split up here you know you
used to be your fire team being Bill
Fred and Joe and all of a sudden you're
not with Bill Fred and Joe and a matter
of fact you're a junior guy and everyone
in your fire team that you randomly end
up as all junior guys as well no one
knows they need to step up and charge
finally you look around and say I gotta
make a call right now hey fire team it's
on me we're gonna pound forward ready
move and you guys listen to you why
because they're starting to adapt to the
situation so they thought we all start
off with like pretty clear guidelines
super general but pretty clear every
seal knows what to do when you say
contact front
everybody knows what to do yeah and then
you say senator peel everybody knows
what to do everyone's done that drill
thousands of times but then while
they're doing the center peel you say
contact rear and then you so now they're
jumbled up but then you call another
call and you say contact rear and then
you say the tactical call for we're
going to flank them and now people start
to work the flank but they're with a
different group and now as that flank is
happening you call contact front or
contact rear again or contact left or
contact right and now we've got to start
to orient to this new situation and so
you just keep doing all these different
calls and it makes people think and like
I said it would felt like I was cheating
because by the time we would get to land
warfare they would throw the the the
problems at you mmm the problems would
not be problems because we already
scrambled our brains over and over again
and everyone knows how to look around
and figure out who to grab and hey if
I'm alone or I'm no one's in charge cool
them to grab three guys we're a fireteam
we're gonna move wow that's so
interesting that like cuz okay you split
football and Brett it's the exact same
thing so what you know you know you
heard of all line screams you're gonna
call inaudible right basically all that
means is I'm changing the play because
of the defense I see or whatever and
then there's little maneuvers you can do
you can be like I know we know this team
plays this certain defense or whatever
so we're gonna lie
up a certain way that means they're
gonna line up a certain way then we're
gonna call the audible on the line and
we're gonna scramble because we already
know where we're gonna shift to and then
right when we shift we're going when we
shift they have to shift to but they're
reactive so I think I don't make all
these decisions right there right before
the play so you should catch them off
guard like that so now imagine if you
did that three times in a row four time
oh yeah
five times in a row yeah and then
they're gonna have real problems yeah
yeah sure but that's crazy how like seal
team practice and training or whatever
like the parallels with like basically
team sport cuz that's well do the same
thing same exact thing they'll you know
it looks different on the field
obviously is a different sport but they
do the same thing yeah and I think for
the takeaway is like to just being a
leader in general what you're putting
you're putting your troops into
situations that they're not familiar
with they learn how they learn a
protocol they learn how to deal with
those situations in which I wrote about
in in in the code I wrote about how do
you handle a situation when you don't
know what to do what do you do well I'll
just break out right that's cuz we're
here because it's a good protocol it's
it's it's a very and it's the it's the
protocol that you have to follow up on
the most because it's the unknown right
the other protocols are straightforward
you know here's the problem here's the
solution this is the unknown what do I
do when I don't know what to do
something bad happen I don't even know
where to start this is this this is the
strategy protocol every scenario cannot
be addressed so this is the protocol for
what to do when you don't know what to
do one start by taking a step back
detach take a breath look around make
sure you assess everything that's
happening so that's what we do you so
this is what's happening when you're in
a seal platoon and there's three calls
just got made and now you're in the
unknown you don't know what to do take a
step back to attach take a breath look
around make sure you assess everything
that's happening that's that's exactly
what you should do hmm next think about
where your possibilities are and
decisions you could make right now and
what could happen so now you look around
say okay what could we do could we go to
that berm over there could we go to that
little ravine over there and here I say
write it down because we're in an
administrative situation but then you
look at okay what what
success look like does that get us where
we want to be can I get there can I make
that happen and then you work the plan
make a call and you want to make small
sit make a small step towards what you
think is the right decision and that's
what I read about in in leadership
strategy in tactics which is the
iterative decision-making process which
is making small steps in the direction
that you think is correct and yeah and
then you assess if that was a good call
or not and you saw the ravine you
started moving towards the ravine
there's doesn't seem like you're taking
any further contact from that area so
you can keep moving there so you can
make another call that continues you
pushing in that direction but what
happens is everybody on the team starts
to realize how to how to do all those
little steps so that new guy that when
you walked out on the beach for the
first time this guy has no idea and
what's cool is this isn't a drill that
you had to run every single day you
could run this drill like three or four
times and then people would just be good
enough where you know you're like okay
we got this and they're there they are I
was gonna say ten times better and then
I was gonna say a thousand times better
than that sounds it sounds unrealistic
but the but the actual number is when
you walk out on the beach for the first
time as a new guy and you've never done
this before
you're zero mmm you're zero you when
that first call when the no when the
first call gets made you go cool I know
what to do when the second call gets
made you're at a zero you have no idea
what's happening so when you've done
this now for three hours one morning
when you're done with those three hours
you're a whole new man you heard a whole
new man your ability to process what's
happening your ability to figure things
out your ability to grab two or three
other people put them in your fireteam
and start making making taking action to
support whatever calls being made you're
a totally different human being in three
hours which is amazing and by the way
the only training that the only
equipment that you need is a pair of
shorts and a stick and you can say bang
bang
mmm-hmm next placing individuals in
appropriate positions Wu Chi said the
basic rule of warfare that should be
taught is that men of short stature
should carry spears and and spear tip
halberd the tall should carry bows and
crossbows the strong should carry flags
and banners that courageous should carry
bells and drums the weak should serve in
logistics the wall the wise should be
involved in planning people from the
same village or district should be
grouped together so they can look out
for each other I got a kind of a kick
out of that one
it's if you think about you know once
you're carrying once you're carrying
guns a lot of the physical differences
between humans go away you know you know
not that they go away completely I was
thinking about the dealer I got a text
from one of my seal friends that might
you know a guy that I grew up with in
the teams and he's just a incredible
beast of a specimen of a human being
right and I remember I was watching we
were doing a training operation we were
down in the jungles of Louisiana and we
were doing a raid a live-fire raid so
we're using really real bullets and I
was in the base element which is the
cover element so we I was not gonna move
I was laying there this is generally the
place for the radio men generally the
first place for the platoon commander
that you're gonna sit next to the team
commander and and you usually would be
looking at rear security and then you so
you put down cover fire and then the
assault element moves into position and
then assaults through the target and you
ship fires they move through anyways the
point of all this is that they had this
kind of mmm semi cheesy target setup for
us there was you know some some couple
plywood buildings some barrels and there
was a picnic table a random like picnic
tables in there and I'm watching the
silhouette of this assault happened
and I see my buddy and you know he's
like 6 4 and just sort of and just
overall general beast of a dude and a
great athlete and I see him he's
carrying an m60 machine gun this was
before the the modern machine guns that
we have novice so this is that big
normally it's a crew serve there used to
be a crew-served weapon meaning you have
a person to carry the weapon and a
person to carry the ammunition and
sometimes a person to carry the tripod
we had him with bipods we had
modifications to them but in the SEAL
Teams you carry those weapons by
yourself so he's got this big giant
weapon and I'm watching him and he he
gets to this picnic table and he's
shooting because they're shooting it's a
live fire and we have now shifted fire
we've actually now ceased fire so we're
no longer shooting we're just watching
them move for the target and I see him
he's carrying this giant m60 and it
looks like he's carrying a BB gun
because that's just big and he's just
laying down fire and he steps up on this
on this picnic table as if it was as if
he was stepping over an anthill and I'm
like like yeah if this dude this dude
was born to be doing what he's doing
right there with that pig that pig gun
so that's what I was thinking about when
I thought of this section right here
that you know you and you know look your
point man a lot of times appointment are
these small guys hey the Vietnam point
man they were legendary those B's the
small seals right hey that guy's gonna
be a point man the big dumb new guys
you're gonna be a 60 gunner right they
still kind of carry this stuff out and
of course it's not written in stone and
you can definitely be there's plenty of
guys that have been very small and
carried and carried a heavy machine gun
there's plenty of big guys that have
been point men but we do you know
there's a little bit does it make sense
yeah it makes sense when you say Pig
what is that what does that mean does
that mean the m60 or does that mean just
a big gun what that means it used to
mean the m60 but now it also means the
mark 48 which is the new modern version
it's a big belt-fed machine
to put it in clear terms for you it's
the iconic Rambo weapon and commando
belt-fed machine gun I don't know about
commander know what kind of weapon he
was carrying in their 60s like shooting
everybody from the hip carrying the the
the bullets right the belt but every
other hand fed machine gun yeah yeah
Rambo I think kind of did it before come
in if I'm not mistaken yeah when he came
back you shooting up the office oh yeah
so so picture that weapon I mean cuz
well now you can picture with with Sly
Stallone right yeah well you know how do
you now tall Sylvester Stallone is on
not exactly but I know that he's not as
tall it's like a you know your guys yes
full exactly and Arnold yeah so you can
picture my buddy just laying them down
and by the way having that thing
shouldered you know like shouldered like
a rifle and just laying it down yeah as
he's moving as he's walking over an
obstacle like it's no factor I know and
I'm totally picturing it and yes that's
a that's a glorious vision for sure
right there when I was young we're
watching Rambo and comment' they'll see
and I was young we were doing assaults
by fire in the swamps of Louisiana
you were watching ramble yes and death
completely different for sure no I think
that's pretty much the same more or less
yes and my dad commented on that he said
because he saw if I'm not mistaken
Arnold Schwarzenegger in commando that's
when we swash together and he had it
yeah but shooting from the hip one hand
holding the the bullets to the other
belt in the other hand and he's just
laying he's just mowing down everybody
right in the little plantation wherever
he was and my dad said he's like man
like that's impressive you see that gun
that he's carrying right there I was
like yeah he's like that gun it would
take me you and then he named like our
neighbor who's you know okay it's like
it would take all three of us to pick
that gun up the thing that say it
because my Arnold's horn nails one hand
so it's interesting you say that because
damn that's what my dad said back in the
yeah I mean you can you can definitely
do what I do and it guys would do that
too but the pig so yes that heavy
machine gun the heavy belt-fed machine
gun is generally referred to as the pig
yeah and therefore the guy that's
carrying the pig can be no can call it
the pig gunner and then if you remember
Ryan job and was a pig gunner and
usually guys have a nickname for their
Pig and as a matter of fact the guy that
was stepping over the picnic table he
his Pig he had two of them I'm not sure
which one of them was called
Frankenstein but the other one was
called roadblock you know this isn't the
night news man there's no war going on
but let's face it roadblock is a legit
dude yeah what is that
Ryan jobs ryan job's nickname was bagels
and his his gun was called bagels so
road block is from GI Joe what is the
name of a weapon know of a guy good luck
or no cops might be cops that's not a
cartoon I don't know I just know that my
buddy had had an m60 that was called
roadblock that's yeah that's one of the
most legit names yeah I'll tell you what
so every different military has their
different schools right your different
skill sets
sniper radio men you know medical
they'll valve their own little schools
and we used to share schools we know
sometimes our radio MinnKota go to the
special forces communication school for
a long time with special forces medic
school so we share some of those schools
sniper school there's a Marine Corps
SMAP but there's all different schools
we are the seals run really really good
schools because you get guys that are
way way way into it way into it mmm way
into whatever their little thing is but
we would run that the machine gunners
would go through a course while we would
go through land warfare and it was like
this is the 60 Gunners course mmm or the
pig Gunners course but man they would
get some of the instructors in there
which everyone was just so into it that
and I know I would
the other guys like I when I was already
2 min or when I was an officer we would
get we and we could use a couple runs
cuz you got it but these guys would be
out there for you know three days just
burning through ammunition and learning
to you everything and slap feet and push
beating combat feet and you know it just
the guys would get so good and you'd see
that's another from another friend of
mine I had I was it was almost the exact
same situation I think I was behind him
we were I was walking on us so we were
assaulting through a target and he was
out ahead of me so I wasn't I was like
as the radio Menace of I was in Alaska
as a radio man you're doing time on
target you get like the nerd roles you
know the stereotypical
so the stereotypical 60 gunner he's like
a big jack guy right even in every movie
right it's the way it is a stereotypical
radio man what does he look like he's a
nerdy guys got glasses on I guess keep
cleaning him in the fields and and so
like I was I was not I mean I wasn't
small but that's the job that I had was
that nerdy job so when you're assaulting
a target your job would be to keep time
on target so you'd call out you one
minute and so your while the assaults
going down sometimes I would be tracking
I'll kind of be I would be a little bit
more heads up I'd be a little bit more
detached right I got three machine guns
out in front of me plus all the other
guys with the pea shooters and they're
all laying it down and I might take a
step back to be okay I'm making calms
I'm making sure we're doing good
whatever but I was watching one of my
other buddies and I just like he was so
there's a there's a feed tree there's a
bunch of different ways that you can
reload your m60 and I just remember him
he in the most smooth fashion that you
could imagine the particular he was he
was slapped feeding it so he opens up
the feed tray and he opens up the feed
tray and he whips his hand he whips his
hand and when he does when he whips his
hand is he hits the Lynx so the you know
those bullets in the belt they're held
together by links and
that when you fire that last round
sometimes that link will sit there it
won't make it out of the gun because it
just fired and so that link will sit
there right in that spot yeah so he
opens up the fitra he whips his hand and
and he hits that and then that link
comes up he opens it up link and while
he's whipping it he he's like prepping
he whips it he switches hand he grabs
out his or no he whips it he grabs the
belt puts the next belt in there boom
slaps the feed cover home Lippe and he
starts and I was like man so what I'm
saying is when you've got people that
are into what they're doing they're
gonna be good they're gonna be good
you want it that's why if you we should
have videoed those two guys do in those
two moments if I could capture those two
moments and just propagate those two
moments to the world people will be a
lot less apt to want to mess with
America because you think about what
kind of humans are doing this what kind
of human is figured out how to open the
feed tray cover slap that link out reach
down again what kind of human is doing
that and has made that into a beautiful
thing yeah that's that's what you're
dealing with
you're not dealing with normal people
we're going distance it's like you know
those guys who you know they they're
into smoking you know so they and I
don't mean like they're just smoking I'm
saying they're into smoking you know so
when they like this cigarette they got
the old-school classic gold-plated
lighter and they do the little mini
micro performance before they light this
cigarette buddy you know I'll flip it
like it's a butterfly knife or something
like that kind of like that but yeah as
far as a war fighter goes yeah yeah and
then you just break down and when I
start thinking about all the little
details like guys would do every little
piece of gear they're honing it they're
clear prepping it everything is taped
everything is quiet everything is just
and you'd get to see these guile tell
you what I was out on patrol like
towards the end of the Battle of Ramadi
so you know we're like a I don't know
maybe a few weeks or whatever from going
home and I run to some corner and I'm
holding the corn rest you know whatever
were just on patrol and I'm watching as
the guys are moving and I'm like good
same thing I'm thinking if I was an
insurgent I would this there's no way I
would take a shot at these guys right
now it looks like a looks like just a
machine a machine a machine that's alive
like a cyborg a cybernetic organism
that's that's conducting operations with
one thought process you know that cannot
be bargained with and cannot be reasoned
with feel pity or remorse or fear yeah
absolutely will not stop ever and and as
we know you are dead like that's from a
movie yes but that's real yeah think
about that that's a that's a movie
somebody wrote that for a movie to make
that as cool as possible but that's a
real thing yeah there's really really
people like that I know them yeah and
there's groups like that and look the
only thing is you can say oh they can't
be killed or whatever is did you say
that or they can't be stopped
it can't be bargained with can't be
bargained reason or reason with cool
yeah we're there yeah so it's just a
good comforting feeling to know that
there's guys out there like that they're
like that yeah I know JP to Nell I known
him for a while for surely he's always
come off as like that yeah yeah good
times good times
well a little fun fact Michael Biehn is
the guy who played Kyle Reese who is the
character who said that whole thing to
Sarah Connor in Terminator 1 and we
might call this layers we might call it
coincidence we might call it parallels
but his most played role is a Navy SEAL
interesting
the abyss the rock there are others too
next section maintenance of horses this
is an interesting one I'm trying to
remember why I highlighted that I should
read that there must be some reason
Lord Wu asked how do we take care of our
horses Wu Chi replied the stable should
be cleaning comfortable all that's why
because it applies to everything the
stable should be clean and comfortable
the horse should be fed with appropriate
grass and water feeding should be until
neither too hungry or too full oh yeah
so this is like a dichotomy here not too
hungry discipline clean right not too
hungry and then it the the dichotomies
continue in winter they should have warm
stables in the summer a cool stables
little dichotomy there their main in
hair should be kept trimming their Hoos
properly cared for yes see these are
guys these are like pig Gunners but with
horses right they should be trained to
be familiar with all sights and sounds
so that they aren't easily startled
practicing their gallop and pursuit
exercise constraint in VAT and halting
the BOM between the horse and men should
be so strong before the horses can be
employed imagine the bond between a pig
gunner and his weapon right it's like a
real thing the equipment such as saddles
bridles bits and reins must be strong
and durable normally these horses are
injured either towards the end of war or
at the start similarly they are either
injured by hunger or over feeding that's
the same that thing that Dave Burke said
about crashes plane crashes they usually
happen in the first 20 percent of a
pilot's career or the last 20 percent
management of troops would she say don't
airy capabilities and civility can be
commander of an army mm-hmm he must be
one who is strict and flexible as well
you thought I made up the dichotomy of
leadership
I didn't been around for apparently
thousands of years strict but flexible
as well in general when people appraise
generalship they usually focus on
courage however courage is but
one of many required characteristics of
a general being only courageous one
would Raschi rush into battle without
any considerations for gain and loss
what do you need to be balanced such
action is not acceptable now the affairs
to which the general must have managed
are five first is control second is
preparation third is commitment fourth
is caution fifth is regulation control
is governing the masses just as one
controls a few preparation is during the
journey to the battleground always be
prepared for enemy ambush commitment
means entering combat without any
concerns for one's life caution means
that even after conquering one remains
the same control and attitude as if just
entering a battle hmm even after you win
you maintain control and you maintain
the same attitude as if you just entered
the battle regulation means laws and
orders are to be kept to a minimum and
non-abrasive
you know what I've been saying lately
lead with the minimum force required
which is exactly what this says right
here orders captain minimum non-abrasive
to accept command without declining to
accept command without declining so when
you get put in charge you do it destroy
the enemy only afterward destroy the
enemy and only afterwards speak about
returning is the proper form of behavior
for general you look you don't talk
about going home you didn't even mention
going home until you win when the army
goes forth his only thought is to die
with glory rather than live with shame
woochi said oh sorry this is four areas
to note in characteristics of good
generals over 2,000 years old mmm
woochi said in general there are four
vital points to note for warfare and
they are morale terrain Affairs and
strength the control management of
Army's movement lies in the hand of one
general that is the vital point for
morale when the road is narrow and
perilous at the vital point of the
mountain route deploying ten men a
general can stop an army of thousands
that is a vital point of terrain making
full use of spies using like cavalry to
harass the enemy sowing discord between
the ruler and officials and higher ranks
and lower ranks were approaching each
other is the vital point of affairs when
chariots and strong have strong axles
and secure pins the boats have been
suited with rudders and oars that
officers our third leaf familiar with
the formations and the horses have
trained in pursuits and maneuvers such
as the vital point of strength one who
knows these four is qualified to be a
general moreover his reputation virtues
benevolence and courage must be
respected by his subordinates and calm
the masses it's interesting that you
think of these guys back in the day of
these rulers being regional ruling with
an iron fist and it's the caste system
and you're just dominating and he talks
about benevolence all the time and
righteousness and how that's he's saying
if you know if you've got a you've got a
group that loves their leader don't even
attack him mm-hmm
furthermore he must be able to scare his
enemy with his reputation and
decisiveness when he issued two orders
no one dared a bit disobey him whenever
he may be wherever he may be rebels will
not dare to oppose him gaining such a
person the state will grow strong losing
him the state will perish this is what
we call a good general characteristics
and importance of good communications
woochi said now the different drums
gongs and bells are means to all
the ear flags banners and pennants are
meant to all the eye prohibitions orders
punishments and fines are meant to all
the mind since the air is awestruck by
sounds they must be loud and clear since
the eye is straw awestruck by colors the
colors must be discriminating and bright
since the mind is awestruck by penalties
it has to be strict and on impartial if
these three are not established even
though you may have the support of the
state you will invariably be defeated by
the enemy thus it is said that word
whatever the generals manners are the
whole troops will go and wherever the
general points to everyone will charge
forward without concern for their own
lives as much as we talk about
communication in its under the it's
under the law of combat simple simple
clear concise communication if you're
not doing that if you're not giving
clear concise orders things are gonna
fall apart
whoosh knowing the enemy general knowing
the enemy general Wu Chi said in general
one essential of Wars to know who the
enemy general is and evaluate his talent
in a corner of the situation use schemes
and achieves new schemes to achieve
results without much later labor a
commanding general who is stupid and
trusting can be deceived and entrapped
one who's greedy and insensitive to
honor can be given gifts and bribed one
who changed his mind
easily and lacks real plans plot to
labor and tire him out that's a good one
you got someone that tries all these
different things cool let him keep
trying all those different things that's
a little nice little breakdown he just
gives about what kind of personality
you're dealing with and then how you
attack that personality it's so good if
the upper ranks are wealthy and and
arrogant while the lower ranks are poor
and resentful
so discord amongst them if they're
advancing and withdrawing are often
marked by doubt and the troops have no
one to rely on they can be frightened
off they can get fright be frightened
into running off if the officers despise
their commanding general and have strong
intent to return home block off the easy
roads leaving the treacherous ones open
then they can be attacked
and captured if the terrain over which
they advance is easy but the retreat
route is difficult wait for them to come
forward
testing the enemy general Lord Wu asked
if two armies are confronting each other
and I do not know their general if I
would like to know more about them what
methods can I employ Wu Chi replied
gather some lower ranks men who are
courageous and have them lead some light
shock troops to test him when the enemy
responds to earth to attack they the
shock troops should run off and he
basically goes through how to do little
probe to find out what kind of reaction
you if they give an organized defense or
not and you can judge from their next
one chaos and communications Lord Wu
asked if the chariots are sturdy the
horses are well bred the generals are
courageous and the soldiers are strong
but when you sell a suddenly encounter
the enemy and the troops are thrown into
chaos and formations are broken what can
be done so this is exactly what I talked
about doing these sand rattle battle
drills on the beach Wu Chi replied in
general it is a rule of battle that
during daylight flags banners and
pennants to relay orders while at night
gongs drums horns and whistles can be
used and said when the flag signal left
they move left when the set flags and
the right they move right when the drum
is beating the advance when the Gong
sound they retreat at the first sound of
the horn they should advance at the
second sound of the horn they should
gather if anyone disobeyed the order
they should be executed this is where I
started to say okay we talked about
levelling sand I was on board we talked
about taking care of your people and I
was on board people disobey your order
execution might not be the best thing to
do only in this way the army would
submit to your awesomeness and the
officers and soldiers will not dare
disobey orders in combat no enemy will
be stronger than you nor will any
defenses remain impregnable to your
attack when the when outnumbered by the
enemy lord Wu
what if our troops are outnumbered Wu
Chi replied avoid engaging them on flat
terrain instead attack in narrow
quarters thus it is said for one to
ten nothing is better than narrow
passage pretend to attack 100 nothing is
better than a deep ravine these are
pretty straightforward how to attack a
strong enemy lord Wu asked if their
forces are numerous well-trained and
courageous behind them are dangerous
high grounds on the right or mountains
on the left or river they are well
fortified and have crossbows and
defending position when they withdraw
they are steady as mountains when they
attack they're like torrential rain as
their food stocks are plentiful it will
difficult to defend against them for
very long what should be done this is
fun this is asking these totally insane
situations right but don't worry have no
fear because Wu Chi replied a very good
question such enemy cannot be overcome
by force alone but by the wisdom of sage
it can prepare one thousand chariots and
10,000 cavalry and support them with
foot soldiers divide them into five
groups each one traversing a different
route now the five groups will move out
in different direction simultaneously
the enemy will certainly be confused and
will not know what we are up to so he
basically goes through how to attack
from five different directions at the
same time and then what he says you
basically want to isolate some of the
groups which is a smart move and then he
goes on to a whole section of when
surrounded by the enemy when caught and
unfavorable to terrain caught in a
valley fighting marine battles wet and
dry weather also known as moist dry
weather
fighting plunders after crawl this is a
good one after conquering cities Wu Chi
said in general there is a principle to
follow when attacking the enemy's city
that is after conquering the city enter
their public building control and use
the former bureaucrats to take over
their supplies relay orders that troops
are not supposed to cut down trees
destroy houses take the grain slaughter
animals or burn people's supplies this
will show the populace that you do not
have any fishs intentions excepting
those that accept those that surrender
and settle them this is very good advice
especially that bureaucratic idea you
know we're gonna take off we're gonna
try and maintain their society we're not
gonna rip it apart it's gonna be easier
to control it's gonna be more beneficial
to you and them mmm it's a positive
thing you know this is the going back to
the Iraq war and the disbanding of
Saddam's military which is pretty much
now considered that that was a bad bad
move we talked about it on we talked
about it on the other podcast the new
the newly named podcast the podcast
formerly known as the thread which is
now known as the jockle unraveling
podcast which will be up soon next
section and just to go back look we
don't have to take this from a war
scenario when you acquire a business
you're a business buys their business
what do you do say yeah we're here
get on board fire all their leadership
no actually utilize their leadership
take some of their culture incorporate
them into the game you know what makes
people not do what I just said because
there you go they're like oh you know
what echo we just bought your company
you're fired or even like like you know
you can use me work as my you know
whatever yeah you I'm gonna take your
authority away from you now everybody's
looking you that should be working hard
and they're going out man they're
treating our boss bad yep it's true you
know good examples of that is the movie
invasion of the Body Snatchers so
there's old-school movie by the way my
dad used to be super into it but I
noticed the aliens that come down and
they take over your body right now there
what's this movie called invasion of the
Body Snatchers so they come down and
they take over your body but you'll
still look like you you can't even act
like you but you have an alien agenda
see zoom same mmm it's the exact same
thing so as opposed to like exactly
because then the alien came invaded your
body took over your body your whole
thing uh-huh
but they didn't like ruin it they kept
your whole
in Susa expecting yeah as far as that
that philosophy goes as opposed to like
men in black
everyone's men in black that one yeah
but I can't really remember to so
there's cockroach alien that came and
like took over this farmer guys body and
it is jammed it up so when this guy the
farmer the alien the cockroach alien was
walking down the street as the farmer
like his body was so jammed up his
skin's all falling down or whatever
everyone was like like he couldn't
function in society seemed saying so
this agenda was it was way harder to
execute you seemed saying I ended up
losing in the end too by the way okay
yeah
coincidence nope no no they kind of
stole that plot line from wuji yeah all
right
Lord woo asked is making punishment
severe and rewards clear adequate for
victory woochi replied as to these
matters of severity and clarity I do not
have all the answers even so they cannot
be totally relied on when you issue
orders and the people willingly follow
them when you raised the army and
mobilize the masses that people take
pleasure in going to battle when
engaging the enemy the people take on
pleasure in fighting to the death
then these three are what the ruler of
men can rely on those are big asks Lord
woo inquired further how does one attain
such results right so this is little big
ass that you're asking for how do you
get there woochi replied you should
identify man of accomplishment and honor
them with a grand feast also invite
those that have not accomplished
anything this would stimulate them
thereupon Lord woo had sitting on had
sitting mats set out in the ancestral
temple Hall arranged in three tiers and
held held a feast for officers and chief
officials those distinguished by great
achievements at in the first tier and
were feasting in the finest food and
cutlery those who ranked in the next
accomplishment sat in the middle tier
and dine with fine food and less lavish
vessels those who had not accomplished
anything noteworthy sat in the last tier
feasting
food in ordinary utensils when the feast
was over and they came out Lord Wu also
honoured the parents and families of the
meritorious outside the temple gate
again according to their accomplishments
he annually sent emissaries to call on
the families of those who had died in
service for the country bestowing aid on
their parents so doing he showed that
they would not be forgotten once again
take care of your people and I also like
how he set up that little tiered
structure of you want to move into the
next tier gotta go make some stuff
happen yeah and also interesting to that
third tier is actually sounds still
pretty solid you know where it's like
dying on the finest food just in some
ordinary cut you know kind of thing but
then you compare to like the lavish top
tier we all want to get there Jack this
is the last section from Wu Chi yeah I
read a bunch of it didn't read the whole
thing you can go download it yourself
for the for the details this is the last
section and this tells a little story
and now we get to this point the day
before the battle Wu Chi spoke to the
troops all aides and officers must
confront and capture enemies chariots
cavalry and infantry' if the chariots do
not make prisoners of the enemies
chariots the cavalry do not make
prisoners of the enemy's cavalry the
infantry do not make prisoners of the
enemy's infantry then even if we Forge
an overwhelming victory
no one will be accredited with
achievements that was that was his
message to the troops on the day of
battle although his orders were not
onerous meaning he'd give these massive
works he just said that right there
basically on that day his awesomeness
shook the world that is the last line of
the Wu Zi written by Wu Chi on that day
of battle his awesomeness shook the
world and I'm gonna say that that's
probably a pretty positive
come and you know look these principles
we read them we have some level of
understanding of them we see the same
advice coming from different people over
a spread of thousands of years we keep
hearing the same type of advice over and
over again what we didn't do is put that
advice to work right put these
principles to work not just for yourself
but for your family but for your people
but for your team but for your employees
your bosses your community and the world
and then what you do is you go out and
you shake the world with awesomeness
echo Charles yes sir
speaking of shaking the world with
awesomeness yes how can you help us do
that how can you help us shake the world
with awesomeness well you cannot shake
the world with awesomeness if you are
not yourself
providing awesomeness seem seen
understeer incapable of providing
awesomeness how can you shake anything
with that awesomeness you seem sane yeah
you're not shaking anything with a pure
lack of awesomeness yourself you can
have a hard time what's interesting is
like even back then they say the word
awesome
so you know okay remember this is the
translation all right that's awesome so
my friend Anthony right he he was
actually on my house our first episode
of the podcast when you came over
oh yeah who's that man so anyway he used
to always say the word awesome like just
just inappropriate times in my opinion
right so that kind of turned me off to
the word awesomeness he'd say yeah I met
this girl she was just she was just so
awesome and it's like all right you know
I don't know how like a girl she this
girl must be really something if you're
in awe of this girl seem same because
that's really what awesome is fate it's
aw so whatever anyway so you'd always
use it so it really turned me off
I tease him about it so anytime he's
around I'd be overusing the word awesome
you know then after a while I just
started using it normally you know I you
know how that happens right it talked
about therefore where you you start
using a word just as a joke you know and
then it slowly creeps into your normal
vocabulary that's what awesome is so I'm
rolling with it okay so apparently whoo
cheers were rolling with it as well yeah
not really gonna roll with it so all
right well we got to keep ourselves in
the game you know this game you cannot
be awesome and shake any worlds or
anything with awesomeness if you're not
in the game to begin to turn down on the
path that's my opinion what's the level
of arrogance when you close out your
book by saying you shook the world with
awesomeness it kind of detracts from the
message a little bit oh well humility
look meter is not get yet very high yeah
when you're saying hey you know what I'm
gonna do no factor just no big deal I'm
over here shaking the world with
awesomeness
I agree but I've never even heard a
person make a statement that is this
that might be the strongest possible and
what what what what's stronger than that
let like what's a stronger way of saying
this person made a mark on the world
right yeah shake the world with
awesomeness that shook it yeah yeah oh
yeah it does sound like like a Kanye
West
maybe statement or you know something
like this okay that's something he would
say I'm saying okay oh I I will take
your word for it anyway
be on the path some saying now what are
you gonna do okay the path is like it's
full of and I'm kind of quote you on
this one it's full it's full of
obstacles and traps mmm path it's true
so those obstacles challenges or
whatever we've got something for you got
some supplements this is for your
physical and mental ability to Sam yeah
just ate on the path in the game etc so
chaco feel kind of home line for you for
any pretty much any ailment pretty much
generally speaking it covers at least a
little bit of any ailment that mabus be
bestowed
basically you're just going up or you're
just carrying the theme forward but
because we were shaking the world with
awesomeness now we're just any ailment
well I'm do we're good
you got the Jocko fuel whatever's wrong
with you we got you this will hey me
ailment this will help this will help so
it's just gonna depend on what you mean
by help Hey look we just you know we
just right you don't need to say
anything else you just said it you say
hey look any ailment that you have any
problem you got jockle you're good
that's it it'll help end of
advertisement ever end of talking we're
good any ailment we're good well ladies
docile fuel well let me specify because
some of these ailments we simply don't
have you see them saying like if you
don't need extra produce an example if
you don't need extra point protein in
the form of e DS of a desert some people
they don't need that who doesn't need
that well a lot of people don't need it
but of course we all of course we don't
want that as far as protein goes how can
it get any well then again steak seem
sane steak is not in the form of a
dessert but sort of the same desire yeah
anyway alright well let me start at the
beginning okay joint were afraid that's
for your joints yes if and when or let's
just say if they start to fall are you
gonna narrow down that you started
you're gonna now narrow down your
attracting your statement that ATM with
this is gonna be cured by choco fuel no
well technically I didn't make that
statement uh I said this will help but I
misread you either thing I totally
cheated on that statement because look
if you break your arm and I give you a
leg massage that'll help it won't help
your arms specifically but you know can
they exalt loosen yeah yeah good to go
so there will be benefits and even for
truly any ailment so you're actually
speaking factually anyway don't work for
supercro oil this and antioxidants in
there by the way it's called disease
anthem
it's called ailment crusher discipline
if you want some supplemental discipline
boom got you discipline the supplement
in cans powder form boom whatever you
like did you say crow oil I did super
super yeah cuz really what it boils down
to it not being on super krill and not
being on
warfare is not a good idea no you talk
about uh the the for something of light
right before those are the lights
yeah maybe some light you got to keep it
like you have to in my past fresh you
have to listen to this I think so and
that's what that's what's the super
krill that's what the drink we're fair
that's the discipline too by the way you
know it's all part of the whole circle
of I must say I drink the powdered form
of discipline go like basically all day
long basically we're talking about all
day long you want to you got some you
want to prevent some ailments yeah even
ailment prevention yes is what we're
talking about vitamin d3 get some of
that get some cold war and you can deny
these threatening enemy beasts ailments
oh yeah better out there just get rid of
them before they even show up
oh yeah immune system somebody walks up
to you're immune you some some enemy
walks up to your immune system they see
the d3 and they see the Cold War they're
so like hey that's not they're not
attacking yep they right next category
if don't attack you're correct the
ancient woochi said if you see a body
filled with d3 and a cold war do not
attack is a losing battle yes got the
RTD cans you want to get some you want
to get some Jocko Palmer you do want to
get some Jocko Palmer
this stuff is ridiculously good it the
the stuff is good it's good for you
which is crazy yeah it's crazy
did you see Brian Littlefield it gave me
little video on that on the whole deal
there well what makes it different and I
thought it was gonna be like the
differences in the spirit or something
you know something kind of esoteric and
you can't really like put your friend
but he Branagh he went down the line
there's like all this stuff you know
like okay proprietary but wow this game
well yeah he's talking about the term
proprietary blend which is a way of
masking what you actually have in there
in the quantities that you have in there
yeah which means that you can sell
people things that for a lot more but
even though you didn't put very much of
them in there
yeah it's which is sketch that's
interesting and then when he goes down
the line you know of all the stuff
that's in there it's all transparent
like you know all the ingredients are
like on there and stuff and you man this
is like this that doesn't that is
different than like an energy ultra you
know which men I'm died like the energy
drink Twitter but man when you when you
read this you're like ah how can I even
drink an energy drink now you won't but
here's the thing we're making something
else we're making a ginger ale do you
like ginger ale yes I do okay well
there's gonna be caffeine free ginger
ale coming hmm we don't think we have a
name for it yet
well no this one won't it can or cannot
I mean you can have caffeine free coffee
you can have caffeine free tea so we're
making ginger ale without caffeine
the reason is the real this way I was
gonna say this if the reason I said that
is because I told I told belittle I was
like listen this stuff tastes freaking
delicious and I want to drink it all day
oh yeah and I don't want to
OD on caffeine there's ninety five
milligrams of caffeine in every can of
go so you know you have a can ago maybe
have two a day the maximum you're
supposed to do recommend it is like 400
milligrams of caffeine a day that's
gonna turn me into a psychopath yeah you
you know yeah I don't need that but
here's the problem
love the taste so well it's a little
discipline test cuz you got to draw the
line but also the cool thing is when you
when you're when it's your company the
oh hey you know what I want something
without caffeine yeah and so we're gonna
make that I already I already had I told
I just probably about the six or seventh
iteration of and you still keep it in
all the positive stuff all the good
nootropics all the healthy things that
are in there it's all still gonna be in
there it's just not gonna have caffeine
okay yeah I misinterpreted it like as if
to say like normal ginger ale has kind
of something but no yeah you're right
like there's caffeine in the choco
Palmer or whatever there's a little
element of caffeine in there or a
legitimate limit
um but this is not gonna happen honestly
that way I can drink this stuff all day
long
get the other benefits from the product
one of those benefits being not taste
fully because I know someone that when
they go out for dinner yeah they get
Coca Cola's yes sir which are not no sir
they're not no hey it's the freedom part
the last you're gonna taste like I
mentioned before
Molk and warrior kid monk by the way so
protein in the form of a dessert tastes
good no taste great these were great bad
often do it and you can get some
chocolate white tea in the cans and
about 8,000 pound deadlift do it's just
no big deal I know this doesn't sound
like it's a guaranteed one or something
and you can get all these things at
origin main comm you can get them at the
vitamin shop as well in your local
neighborhood there you go
also a tour domain is jiu-jitsu stuff
when we start jiu-jitsu when we're in
jiu-jitsu we want to get a new key we
want to get a geek or rash guard or
whatever's where'd you me not come they
got that too all made in America
since you can't unfortunately just where
Aggie wherever you go unfortunately
I mean you can technically but it's not
recommended yeah you can also get other
things they're like jeans t-shirts boots
yes boots you can get boots and all
everything that we just talked about
everything without compromise
made in America American hands up
they're getting after it some kind of
thinking of the booth writing and some
other stuff I get it but the boots will
just say the boots so you know how Wu Zi
no Lucci yeah which is it's talking
about like hey you spent a lot of time
making that thing beautiful mm-hmm but
not folks I'm still trying to figure out
they use for it right but these boots
are kind of like whoever made them Pete
and them was kind of doing both seem
saying like when they had the golf or
boots yeah they were like going
functional with Beauty like hand in hand
almost kind of thing where as far as
works of art goes downs like I'm not
that much into fast
like you were but it seems like that'd
be like some top-tier artistic there's
there's a good balance between fashion
and function between myself and a guy by
the name of Pete Roberts uh-huh let's
face it pre well let's face it on a in a
in a vacuum environment with just Pete
Roberts in there all you have to do is
look at rash guards from origin right
you can look at those nude see where
it's gonna we and you inject a little
Jocko and there all of a sudden things
start you know we start going a little
bit more towards the form yeah they're
gonna know a little bit more towards the
form think Pete can get wild
brah like you know likes the way things
look more than me yes sir
more than me quite a bit more than me
yes sir but what's cool is you get that
balance like the jeans band let's face
it there's some things about the jeans
that are a little bit they're functional
like the pockets are slanted in the back
right just easier disagrees little
things yeah they're legit yeah and it
just so happens let's face it they look
super a little doe bright I went to
organ just got back as you know and on
the plane this is saying a lot no I'm
not trying to like look dope cuz the
paparazzi is gonna be at the airport
waiting for me when our ayah that it's
not my situation you know so I wear
what's gonna work in the airport
scenario environment
origin genes all day to and from by the
way so you if the paparazzi was waiting
for you you'd wear something different
no my concern would just lie elsewhere
you seem sane I might even wear
I might even wear like you know those
gold or diamond dreamed sunglasses never
wear so funny but not sane if the
different pursuit is what I'm saying
nonetheless those are the facts also
chocolate the stores called Jacko's
store this is where you can get other
stuff if you want to represent on this
path this is a path that we're all on
the path the game whatever you want to
call it
the way the way the whoo-whoo-whoo wait
right whoo right his way again I tried
to find out if woozi meat meant anything
and the I couldn't find that he meant
anything that I could comprehend other
than a room and I know that this book is
not called a room
yeah but I saw if I'm not mistaken is
called is the way whoo cool I think I
could be wrong but I think whoo by
itself is Marshall as in martial arts as
an e-tank lamb oh okay
it's clear to me now and the last
chocolate the source called jungle store
like I said and if you want shirts that
say discipline equals freedom never seen
a youtube comment that says echo in
quotes like your middle name nonetheless
Charles yes I have seen okay hey man I
can I deny it and you know I guess I
could technically but you know it would
it be less accurate than maybe if I
didn't deny we'll say that unless like I
said back to discipline equals freedom
shirts and hoodies and rash guards and
hats some women's stuff on there anyway
if you want to represent with merch as
it were I don't like to say the word
word merch that much but if you'd like
apparel you want to represent your store
comm subscribe to this podcast if you
want to echo seems to think that's a big
concern in the morning so hey not only
is there this podcast we also have the
the name the the podcast formerly known
as the thread which is now known as the
Jocko unraveling podcast
that's we actually recorded a couple
more with Daryl yesterday it'll be back
and it'll be live we'll put them where
to put them on this feed and then
eventually we'll move them off to
another feed so we don't confuse people
grounded podcasts we haven't done one of
those in a while
that's probably negligence same with
warrior kid podcast but they are there
we will work on more also speaking of
warrior kids we got that we got that
warrior kid so Irish Oaks France calm
or you can get it on the taco store and
this is made by a warrior kid who's
putting his effort in life to create
something so that people in the world
can stay clean we have a YouTube channel
where Echo Charles makes videos he will
put this this will be on there this
whole scenario will be on there yeah you
can you can see what I look like you can
see what EKKO looks like and the echo
then also makes these videos where he'll
in a three minute video by the way
he'll put 900 explosions but in a
three-hour video he'll put none
dichotomy men people are starting to
wonder I think that certain things why
don't you do this once you start with
like today you talked about 14 different
eighties movies why don't you put a
little clip in there or put a little
something make a terminator robot or
something right you just put it in there
people will go oh I don't think they
will because I think explosions
Terminator robots etc are do have levels
of appropriateness given given you have
a bro no limit to the appropriateness of
explosions and for free giving what kind
of video it is so you know we're gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna err on the side of
bro can you at least try to put one
effect into a three-hour podcast video
you know what the jury's still out on
that one whether or not that's a good
decision but we're gonna I'm gonna keep
checking in and you know maybe maybe not
but you know either way we're gonna
we're gonna move forward nonetheless yes
YouTube channel it is there a lot of
people a lot of us will play the podcast
straight up just play it on our TV our
Smart TV you know that's a thing now
mmm-hmm and you know they'll just play
it it's kind of like boom the
conversations going around going on in
the room with you you seem saying it
does create that environment that's what
I'm saying unless tune into that one on
the YouTube that's the way to do it
boom well there's stuff on there some
excerpts on there too if you don't
necessarily want to listen to the whole
thing all at once or whatever you know
cause I got discipline or whatever but
no some people they'll just catch
they're like the YouTube excerpts and be
like oh sure let me just let this one
play it's a good topic spread but it's
just the one topic soon saying that's
good too very beneficial um yeah boom
there you go also psychological warfare
if you don't know what that is is an
album with tracks jhaqo tracks chocolate
telling you helping you really helping
you what you don't want help you don't
need help that's what you're saying no
that's not what you're saying sometimes
we all need a little bit of help
psychological warfare will help you
through those moments of weakness big
weakness small weakness whatever you
will get help through it hundred-percent
hundred-percent I just saw you riff good
job because you didn't repeat this you
know you you stepped off your your
standard okay oh I don't want I can't
say script because it's not a script cuz
you're not reading it it was just the
same thing that you you know when I had
to ban you from saying that while ago
kou yeah I also got flipside campus.com
Dakota Meyers company and he makes
visual representations to keep you on
the path I got a bunch of books the code
leadership strategy and tactics way the
warrior kid one two and three Mikey in
the dragon's discipline equals freedom
Field Manual extremely ownership of the
dichotomy leadership if you like what we
talked about here we wrote them down we
wrote this information down for every
level of child of adult of human you can
start to get on the right path also have
a leadership consultant company it's
called echelon front if you need help
with leadership inside your organization
go to a salon front calm
we have EF online which is where I've
been investing a ton of time going
online interacting we do we right now
we're doing three times a week I'm there
you wanna you want ask me a question and
you sent me a Twitter thing three months
ago and I didn't respond because there
was 19 million of them or you sent me a
Facebook message and I didn't respond
look I apologize I it's not possible for
me to look at them all if you want to
talk to me go to you farm on calm
did you go to your farm on Comm you will
be I will be in your living room with
you on zoom the zoom call I will be in
your living room the you'll be and
you'll be talking to me we'll be having
a conversation that's what's happening
go to EF online.com there's a bunch of
other information on there there's a
bunch of other we got we got courses to
go through we've got a question of the
day we've got leadership primers get all
kinds of stuff so go check it out EF
online.com we really ramp that up and we
got into the Kovac scenario if you want
to come to the muster which is our
leadership event the next one is going
to be in Arizona September 16th and 17th
then Dallas Texas on December 3rd and
4th go to extreme ownership comp for
details look it's probably gonna be a
social distance situation which means
we're gonna have less tickets to sell
which means gonna sell out faster so
extremely cheap calm if you want to come
EF overwatch if you are a military
individual that is moving into the
civilian sector or if you're a civilian
company that needs people that
understand the principles we talked
about here go to EF over watch.com fill
out the appropriate information and we
will move you in the right direction
both of you America's mighty warriors
dot org this is Mark Lee's mom mama Lee
and she is out on a daily basis making
it her mission to help service members
their families the gold star families
around the world so if you want to get
involved or you just want to donate go
to America's mighty warriors org and if
you want some more of my inept
interpretations or you would like to
hear more of echos prolonged
proclamations then you can find us on
the interwebs on Twitter on Instagram
and on Facebook that goes at echo
Charles and I am at Daka we link and to
all the folks out there in uniform
actually enacting and living these
military principles to keep us safe and
free thank you to all of you and to
police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and border patrol and see
good service thanks to all of you for
holding the line for us here on the home
front and everyone else out there listen
Moochie said that maybe we should try to
shake the world with awesomeness but
like he also said stay balanced don't
run with that idea stay on the high road
don't do well in magnificence and power
that's your ego keep that thing in check
instead follow the way how things should
be done do things with righteousness do
things with propriety and that means you
hold the standard that means you conform
it actually means you conform to doing
what is right be benevolent take care of
people and if you do those things and
you do them humbly well then you can get
out there and shake the world with
awesomeness not for yourself but for
others then that is leadership and until
next time this is echo and Jocko out